>>Natalie Walchuk: I
think the number one thing
that has been most effective
here has been really focusing
on relationships, knowing the story
of each member of my community
and that has been one of the
most impactful parts of the work
and also enabled me to
do large chunks of change
with a receptive group
of people behind me,
because we already had kind of a
foundational relationship happening,
and then, secondly, really seeing
the children are this wonderful,
messy mush of needs that range from
academic to emotional to physical,
and so how do we meet
all those on our campus?
>>We have three key things
that support student outcomes.
Dialogue Circles are a great way
for students and teachers to get
to know each other and
learn how to communicate
about hard things in a safe place.
It's an essential practice
of Restorative Justice
and a great place to get started.
>>Student: I think you
should just walk away
and if they still bully you,
then you should tell the teacher.
>>Natalie Walchuk: Every teacher,
every day, uses Circle to check
in with students to see how
they're doing and uses mindfulness
to prepare them for learning.
>>Allison Kenny: Would that work?
>>Natalie Walchuk: We
have art partnerships
with community organizations
that come in and use art as a way
to support critical thinking and
communication skill development.
>>Allison Kenny: And the
only one we're really
in charge of is ourselves.
>>Natalie Walchuk: Every student
gets two art classes per week
as part of their core day.
And then we offer a range of classes
outside of the school day for kids
to participate here on campus.
Many students who maybe are
not as traditionally successful
in the classroom that's the reason
why they want to come to school
and a reason why they want
to engage in academic work,
because they're having another
part of themselves satisfied.
>>Jahi: And all you have are two
index cards and some Sharpies.
What would you create?
>>Natalie Walchuk: We've worked
very hard to create a community
where teachers want to step
outside their classrooms,
talk and work together and
really ask the hard questions.
One thing I found when I came
to Glenview was the staff had a
hard time questioning practice
or being a critical friend and
kind of probing on questions.
So we've worked to develop
a culture where you have
to have ask a constructive question
and that has allowed us to go deeper,
faster during our PD time.